[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a podcast where me and my
brother John gives you dubious advice
answer your questions and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon but first we talk about a week
it has been for AFC women oh well we'll
get to that but first let's just talk
about how our weeks are going not yours
and I think that you've promised us last
time an update on your interactions with
misty Swift Hank I did meet Taylor Swift
she was incredibly nice it was such a
pleasure she also said really nice
things about me and my books from atop
the spinning stage where she performed
it was a pretty magical evening
Oh like on on in front of the in front
of the 14,000 people at Bankers Life
Fieldhouse yes it was a pretty magical
evening and I felt so grateful to be
there I do have to say as much I spent
very little time with Ms Swift herself
but I did spend a ton of time with her
parents who were just lovely ah such
such lovely people and I realized that
you know probably to Taylor Swift it's
appropriate for me to hang out with her
parents because in her mind we are all
about the same age
well aren't you actually about the same
age as Taylor's parents I am me I am
younger than Taylor Swift's parents but
I realized that too - Taylor Swift and
also just too chronological fact I am
closer in age to them than I am
to Taylor herself which was which was a
real awakening for me but no it was so
much fun she puts on such a great show
as you know I'm a huge fan of hers but I
thought that she just did a wonderful
job it was it was just an amazing night
it was really wonderful Vance joy who's
on the Paper Towns soundtrack opened up
for her and he was great as well and so
it was a great week for me and then on
Monday I had this horrific oral surgery
so if my voice sounds a little weird
it's because there's all there's all of
this like cotton and and stitches in my
mouth and stuff
so that was a bit of it that was a bit
of a bummer but other than that things
are great how are you I'm good
we had our company retreat this weekend
so I was very very tired after that and
maybe I maybe may maybe drink a little
bunch and but it was great to hang out
with all the people who helped us
produce scishow and crash course and
VidCon and and since they fell for dftba
records and some of the people came out
from indianapolis and they are great and
we just had a great time so that's that
feels good to be part of a good team and
and and then in addition to that I did
21 interviews for a press junket for for
scishow and our and our work with
Emerson an engineering company that we
that supports site shows content and
that started at 5 o'clock in the morning
and was really hard and it's the second
one I've done and I know you've done a
thousand of them but boy is that
exhausting yeah I find that I cannot
blame anyone for anything they say in a
press junket interview Robert DeNiro got
a bunch of flack last week for walking
out of an interview after saying that
the interviewer was condescending and I
was really moved by the fact that the
interviewer was was was empathetic
toward Robert DeNiro and was like I
don't think that I was being
condescending but to be fair those
things are horrible I don't really blame
anyone for anything that they say in
them and I and that's kind of how I feel
now when I see that you know somebody
said something you know problematic or
off-color or whatever in an interview
that's in a press junket I'm just I you
know III want to I go to see if they
apologize because if they apology I
don't even feel like you have a brain
when you're doing those things
it's just absolutely I feel like my soul
is leaving my body yep but we are
complaining about the first world east
of first world problems um can I read
can I read a poem do you read me a poem
John
Hague today's poem comes to you from
George Bill chair you liked the funny
poem last week so much that I thought I
would read you this one you've heard it
before but boy do I like it it's called
the return of Odysseus
you're familiar with the Odyssey right
Hank yeah I've heard of it too they
McKenna do a movie was it a movie uh
that the too long didn't read version of
The Odyssey is that after a number of
years at war Odysseus goes home but it
takes him like 20 years to go home
hence the it being an odyssey alright
Hank so here is the return of Odysseus
by George bill scher when Odysseus
finally does get home he is
understandably upset about the suitors
who have been mooching off his wife for
twenty years drinking his wine eating
his mutton etc in a similar situation
today he would seek legal counsel but
those were different times with the help
of his son Telemachus he slaughters
roughly 110 suitors and quite a number
of young ladies
although in view of their behavior I
used the term loosely rivers of blood
course across the palace floor I too
have come home in a bad mood yesterday
for instance after the department
meeting when I ended up losing my choice
parking spot behind the library to the
new provost I slammed the door I threw
down my book bag in this particular way
I have perfected over the years that
lets my wife understand the contempt I
have for my enemies which is prodigious
and then with great skill she built a
gin and tonic that would have pleased
the very gods and with epic patience she
listened as I told her of my wrath and
of what I intended to do to so-and-so
and also to what's-his-name and then
there was another gin and tonic and
presently my wrath abated and was
forgotten and peace came to rain once
more in the great halls and courtyards
of my house the return of Odysseus by
George bill scher one of my favorite
poems largely because of its last word
in the great halls and courtyards of my
house not my home not my palace my house
the least pretentious word he could have
chosen in that moment beautifully
beautifully written poem just couldn't
be better start to finish and I thought
that you'd like it Hank because you like
a good funny I do I I find that maybe
might be funny poetry is the right
entrance for most people it seems to be
for me all right well don't don't worry
I'm gonna get very sad and serious next
week okay
make me feel things John Hank would you
like to begin by answering a question
from one of our beloved listeners I
think that it wouldn't be quite correct
to call it beginning but I will continue
with a question from one of our beloved
listeners this one is from Anna who asks
dear Hank and John sometimes I'll notice
that my idea of a person isn't who they
actually are but rather who I want them
to be for me it can be really hard to
stop thinking about them that way and
see them for who they actually are how
would you suggest I do that well Anna
you've asked a big question of being a
person maybe the biggest one
yeah I mean inevitably we're gonna
project our own ideas of other people on
to those people because we're stuck
inside of our own consciousness and we
can never quite imagine what it's like
to be someone else we could never quite
you know do a perfect job of listening
and stop projecting I've been thinking
about that a lot this week because my my
religion professor from college and my
great mentor from college professor
Donald Rogan died this week he was 85
and and lived 15 years longer than I
expected him to I figured that the old
man would die within a year or two of my
graduation because of course in my mind
my presence in his life was the center
of his life but you know but in reality
you know he had a wonderful family a
loving wife of to whom he was married
for more than 50 years beautiful
children and then grandchildren and
great grandchildren and so Dawn had this
you know rich and wonderful life that I
could only glimpse because I was stuck
looking at his life from my own eyes and
kind of seeing myself in the center of
it that challenge I think of like doing
a better job of listening to other
people so that we can empathize with
them better is like the biggest
challenge of adulthood we've talked
about it before on the podcast but like
I yeah I mean that's something that I
still struggle with all the time am i
doing a good job of listening to this
person or am i projecting my own
feelings and ideas onto them
yeah I'll say Anna that the number one
the number one first step is to real
you're doing it which I don't think most
people even do and often times you I
forget that I'm doing it and so that the
real strategy is to just know you're
doing it and and and you know you can
you can try to project you can try to
form a more accurate picture of a person
but but you can never really form an
accurate picture of them and so just
know that you aren't and and that's so
so powerful and even people who have
known each other for very long times I I
will still after twelve thirteen years
of being with my wife I will as she will
do something that I find totally
unexpected and very unlike her and I
will say what why would you have chosen
to do that thing and she's like I what
do you mean this is totally a thing that
I would do and I'm like I guess I guess
I just have I have to work harder on
understanding who you are still yeah I
think in fact I just did this to you
maybe Hank right before we started
recording the podcast we were talking
and I accused you of of pontificating
from a place of knowledge when in fact
it's possible that you were just being
yourself and I was feeling defensive
about my lack of knowledge about
something and in general like it's all
it's just so so hard to listen to even
the people you're closest to it's so
hard to sort of put yourself out of it
because of course like everything that
you hear is filtered through yourself
and through your consciousness and and
it's almost impossible to know when
you're doing it but just being aware of
how how much that's inevitably going to
shape your worldview your own experience
your own you know your own sense of self
I think sets you on the right path
hopefully yes it is a tremendous first
step and I am proud of you for making it
are I think our second question comes
from Emily who's 15 and who writes Dear
John and Hank do you have any advice for
someone who just got their driving
learner's permit I have a piece of
advice Emily
don't drive too much don't don't drive
too much just just drive a little bit
because you and I say this with great
affection
are and are a danger on the roads you
are a threat to me and to my family okay
yes and in addition to that just know
this is very important that you are not
a good driver
this is this is fine Emily I don't know
if Hank and I are doing a good job of
emphasizing this to you enough so let me
just underscore one other thing you
don't drive what and but what I mean
when I say that you are not a good
driver isn't that you might be a good
driver but the number one thing is to
never think that you are a good driver
because it's people who think that they
are good drivers that are the most
dangerous because they have never so
they have never been in an accident
because they've been driving for six
months and they're like well I have
clearly an amazing track record I've
never got a ticket I've never been in an
accident I've never made a single
mistake and and it's when when you are
in that space between knowing your bad
and being good that you are the most
dangerous person that's when uh that's a
very dangerous place if you're learning
how to fly that space between knowing
that you suck and and and then actually
being good when you've stopped when you
stopped remembering that you're you're
not very good but you aren't actually
very good that's when that's when you
die so you're not a very good driver and
that's okay because you're gonna get
better
but but not just that carefully I never
want to think that I'm a good driver I'm
always suspicious of people who are like
I'm a very good driver the only person
I've ever driven in a car with who said
I'm a good driver and I believed them
was a professional racecar driver they
are good drivers he was fundamentally
different as a driver from everyone else
I've ever driven with well I'll also say
that I've driven with professional
drivers who are pretty amazing taxi cab
drivers in London I've felt are just
amazing drivers and we also were driven
on on John's fault no Stars tour by
Julie who is an amazing River
and it was 4years a truck driver and
when you're with an amazing driver like
Julie one of the things that you
recognize immediately is that you are
not very good at this until you're with
a driver like Julie that you realized
that there's a whole world to driving
that you just don't understand you know
there's a whole world to being ready for
any emergency that most of us just
haven't reached yet yeah and so I think
the number one thing that most of us who
are bad drivers like Hank and Emily and
myself the number one thing that we can
do is remember that we are bad and tried
to drive defensively and carefully now
obviously you don't want to drive in
fear but you should drive defensively
and carefully and you should remember
never drive drunk never drive when you
are in any way impaired and to soom that
everyone else on the road is a terrible
distracted driver mm-hmm
Emily I'm sorry if it sounds like our
advice is a little firm on this one but
I just but but yeah when it comes down
to is that driving is the most dangerous
thing that we do and we should be
careful driving is not the most
dangerous thing that I do Hank but
you're not a risk taker all right we've
got another question from another Emily
is that okay can we do two buildings in
a row yeah absolutely is either of them
you think my most important
ex-girlfriend or or not well is your
most important next girlfriend currently
a sophomore in high school
and also the smartest kid in school no
and no all right well emily is and if if
you go off grade point average in test
scores at least but she has this problem
that she has become labeled as some and
and people don't notice her personality
or frankly anything other than her test
scores how does she avoid and/or deal
with being objectified for her
intelligence thank you well I mean the
first thing that I would say Emily maybe
this is the same Emily who's a driver
because they're both 15 maybe well they
do seem to be roughly the same age on
the other hand I my understanding is
that of that generation of young
Americans about 75% of the women are
named Emily I think there may be a lot
of Emily's yes
so Emily the first thing that I would
say is that you have to remember that
like intelligence is separate from test
scores and really any other metric right
like to me
test scores reflect not intelligence but
hopefully if the tests are good mastery
of material so it's not about potential
it's about achievement although I don't
think that like you know what's easily
quantified is often a particularly good
measure of achievement or understanding
so assuming that we're talking about
achievement and understanding and being
able to contextualize your life better
in the universe than most people there's
nothing to resent about that
well III don't think that I I think that
you I think that what emily is saying
isn't necessarily that she is the
smartest like she started out that way
by saying she's the smartest kid in
school but but what she's saying is she
has this problem that that maybe she
doesn't even think that about herself
but that's what everybody thinks that
like that's that that's the niche
everyone thinks like they look at Emily
and they think that's the smartest they
make all of these broad conclusions
about it based on this idea that she's
the smart girl right right and and so
she's being stereotyped and of course
it's there's not the it's a of the
things to be stereotyped for being a
smart girl is certainly not the worst
one
and like and you actually also probably
get a number of advantages because
people assume that you are smart and
they might not they're probably not
social advantages but there are you know
they probably get extra attention from
teachers and and maybe even the
administration and your parents and
probably a lot of support but breaking
out of that and like and like being a
little sick of just being this one thing
to everybody in their mind it can be
very frustrating I would imagine I know
you're right heck I think that anytime
the world sees you as just one thing
it's exhausting because you aren't just
one thing and it's very difficult to
have to constantly meet someone's
expectations for what they think
the smart kid is or what they think the
you know any any simplistic less than
complexly human definition of personhood
is exhausting to have to live inside so
I think the thing that I would recommend
to Emily is just to remember that that
you aren't merely the smart kid but also
to remember that like the people around
you aren't merely the the boxes that you
would put them in that in fact like
you're all extremely complex and like
these these weird huge webs of of
personhood you know what I was thinking
about yesterday Hank what how many
organisms are there inside of my body
there's a lot I mean are there over a
billion living organisms yeah probably
there's over a billion living organisms
inside of my physical corpus right now
uh I would guess yes but like given that
given that there are over a billion
things that are not me
currently inside of me like how how what
can we what what does that even mean
what does me mean me is really like this
gigantic petri dish hosting parasites
yeah I mean you're also there's also a
lot of you and you as well sure there's
I'm sure there's a billion cells that
are me but there's a billion cells that
aren't there's something profoundly
disturbing about that to me anyway my
point Emily is that you are not one
thing you are also like a bunch of
amoebas living inside of your gut or
whatever but um but if you if you know
that at your core then you will you will
chafe against other people putting you
in the box but you will also make it
ultimately I think make it harder for
people to put you in that box yes but I
would also say that the the probably
most common thing that people do when
they find themselves in this place is
that they rebel against that image of
themselves but I would say do your best
not to do that because because rebelling
against being the smart person means
making yourself dumb so don't make
yourself dumb make yourself more
complicated and that's really the lot of
the story of being a human as as
increasing abilities in different ways
and
becoming more more unique than you you
already were
but don't rebel against it and and and
and lose interest in school and and
because that's that's a could have
actual lifelong badness associated with
it because you're smart and you should
be smart and there's nothing wrong with
that I totally agree Hank can I ask you
another question do it I think this
question comes from Walker who asks dear
John and Hank I've been having a problem
lately where I feel annoyed at myself
for watching and enjoying other people's
creations without myself creating
something worth sharing I feel kind of
like a short sound I guess what should I
do to start creating and to live with my
human need for affirmation
first off Walker great question and I
like the fact that you acknowledged your
human need for affirmation I think a lot
of times when I think about that
question I don't think about the
affirmation side of things because you
know in the last several years I've been
very blessed to have lots of outside
affirmation for my work I I think it's
really important to watch and enjoy
other people's creations I think it's
really important to be an audience and I
think that enthusiastic members of an
audience are also creators I don't think
that creative work can exist independent
of an audience so don't sell yourself
too short being a passionate member of
an audience because that is a kind of
creation you are making up the things
that you watch and read and enjoy with
the people who made them and and they
wouldn't exist without you in the sense
that like you sort of like make it real
in a different way when you read a novel
than when anyone else reads the novel
because you are translating the words
and do ideas in your head but I totally
understand like that urge to make things
as well and I think like Hank and I
started out making online video in large
part because we enjoyed being part of
online video audiences so much that we
were like oh we should be on the other
side of the cap indeed that is that is
uh that is how that started I yeah I
think that the hard part of creation
is getting past the part where you're
doing it and no one's paying attention
because you're not that good at it the
great thing about like the wonderful
thing that happened to me and John is
that online video was so new that even
if we were pretty bad we were better
than than the rest of what was happening
which was nothing and so there just
wasn't a lot going on and so it was
easier to stand out and that that and
and then as online video grew we got to
get better at making videos along with
the growth of of online video and and
now we are fairly good at it and but but
have been but people have been paying
attention to us the whole time
which is great and we got so lucky and
nobody gets that lucky and and yeah
nobody gets that lucky and so you have
to have to push yourself to make things
because in knowing that some of the
things are going to make aren't going to
be appreciated because maybe they just
aren't going to be that good or maybe
because it's very difficult to find an
audience for for creations whether or
not they are good sometimes in this
world yeah I mean you got to take a
certain amount of pleasure and joy in
the act of making something and
something that I've realized now that I
know that I have an audience is that you
know at least for me when it comes to
writing having an audience doesn't help
me right it doesn't help it it it
ultimately I think doesn't motivate me I
have to find pleasure and joy in the act
of making the gift regardless of whether
I think that anyone will enjoy or
appreciate the gift I have to find a way
to love making the thing or else
ultimately I will never make it so
you've got to find some at least to me
you have to find some pleasure in the
process and some joy in the process and
honestly it's only been in the last
couple of months when I really started
loving writing again and loving being
inside of a story that I've been able to
make well what I hope anyway is real is
real progress despite you know spending
the last three years trying to work on a
novel and like being very conscious of
of an audience and and I which I'm very
grateful for but I think ultimately
you've got to find pleasure in the make
something John I have been thinking a
thing and I haven't run it by anyone yet
so would you mind if I run it by you now
yeah sure no it's not like anyone's
listening I think that there's only two
things there's how you feel and there's
how effective you are and those are the
two things that we're trying to that
we're all trying to to craft for
ourselves so what like the direction the
effectiveness goes in whether that's to
make your your family happy and healthy
and stable or whether it's to you know
take over a company and become powerful
and control other people's lives or if
it's to cure malaria that's trying to
make this irrelevant to morality but
just say like the there's two things
there's your mood and there's your
effectiveness and the goal is to have a
like maximize the number of days when
you feel happy and pleasant and and then
at the same time maximize your ability
to have effects on the world weather and
and ideally I hope that that those
effects are positive because that's the
kind of effect people want to have do
you think that there are more than those
two things yes I think that is a radical
oversimplification of human life I also
think that that like a lot of your
proposals for worldviews it excludes the
absolute obsolescence that everything
that humans do and make and our will
fall into like everything that we think
and do and make and all of the love that
we feel for each other and everything
everything about people every human
creation and every human being will fall
into an absolute black hole and they're
okay like a no legacy forgot anything
yes we're all gonna die not just we're
all going to die but that like
everything's going to stuff exists right
like I mean I'm not forgetting the
entire theme of our podcast
it's a comedy podcast about death not
just that but the absolute universal
obsolescence of all things including the
universe itself but I think that that
what I when we talk about effectiveness
like we talked about affecting the
things that we care about yeah yeah but
I think like so my argument my
counter-argument is that you're
oversimplifying because people who don't
want to be like capital e effective they
want to be effective in certain ways and
the reasons they want to be effective in
various ways is about more than mood and
urge toward effectiveness like I think
that I think that culture and the social
order shape shape lots of that stuff but
I also think that that individual people
within social orders also you know also
also make changes for reasons other than
wanting to be happy or wanting to be
effective I think that altruism plays a
role I think that narcissism plays a
role I think that um I I always feel
like it's a little bit more of a
complicated stew than you can fit onto a
bumper sticker well what's the fun in
that though maybe we should just put
that on a bumper sticker
this is a more complicated stew than you
can fit on a bumper sticker on a bumper
sticker right my consciousness is a more
complicated to than you can fit on a
bumper sticker a bumper sticker
available now at dftba.com today's
podcast is brought to you by dftba.com
your friendly internet detailer for dear
Hank and John merchandise that does not
exist yet uh this podcast is brought to
you by the smartest kid in school the
smartest kid in school turns out to be a
lot more complicated than you think
and you should give them a little more
credit for their for the the various
nosov their consciousness this podcast
is brought to you today by 15 year old
drivers 15 year old drivers please
please God please God just be careful
[Laughter]
good Hank I think we have time for one
more question before we get to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon ah this
question is from Alex he writes dear
John and Hank what do you think of
English class I can
heartedly say that the only thing I've
gotten out of all the classes I've taken
is an increased vocabulary I don't think
that reading anything that's been
assigned to me has helped me with
anything else in life for some
perspective I just graduated high school
and will be majoring in computer science
at University maybe it just doesn't help
me yet but I can't help but feel like
I've wasted a lot of time reading these
books and I just see English class as
someone telling me how to have fun well
Alex you're not gonna like my answer you
might like Hanks answer everybody wants
me to say that English classes are
useless and that they like kill books by
dissecting them and they take those the
soul out of reading in yadda yadda yadda
and I just don't agree with that at all
I feel like if you haven't gotten
anything out of English class that might
be the fault of your English teachers
but it's most likely your fault because
you know we have this glorious record of
human storytelling that stretches back
more than a thousand years where we can
understand like what mattered to people
and why what mattered to Nathaniel
Hawthorne what mattered to Shakespeare
what mattered to to Chaucer and then you
know what mattered to Homer when he was
writing the Odyssey but even putting
that aside to me the most important
thing that we get from English class is
an understanding of non-literal
communication and I would argue that
like essentially all of the most
important communication is non-literal
that like symbolism and metaphor are the
main ways that we approach one another
as human beings and the main ways that
we seek to understand each other like I
cannot really talk to you about my soul
about the experiences and pain and joy
that's inside of me without using
symbolic language I mean once some would
argue that like language is inherently
symbolic and that when you for instance
are engaging in computer science like
you are essentially trying to use this
symbolic language to translate ideas
that exist in your mind and to programs
that can be useful to people which is
what literature is trying to teach but
putting that aside because I know Hank
will disagree with me there i I think
that like trying to understand how we
use language symbolically to communicate
ideas to each other is absolutely
is sensual like that is something that's
really really important and the truth is
that the books that you read in high
school are very useful for that now Hank
is gonna disagree with me because I know
he didn't read any of the books and in
his high school English class and now he
has this incredibly sophisticated
symbolic imagination which he absolutely
does but that's my own experience of of
the benefit of high school English
classes is that for me it was a way into
reading about the ways that people who
live lives very distant from mine
approach the big questions of being a
person and then secondarily learning
about symbolism and metaphor as a way of
communicating my internal experience to
other people and appreciating their
internal experiences when they describe
them to me alright Alex I hope that I
have a satisfactory answer for you as
well as John's very satisfactory answer
but maybe one that will hit a little
closer to home for your clearly
analytical mind we're really bad at
knowing what affects us we're really bad
at knowing what builds us and what makes
us who we are I felt the same way as you
when I graduated from school that I had
gone through a lot of classes that
didn't have a serious impact on me and
yet when I look back at how I felt and
saw the world when I was a freshman in
high school versus how I saw and felt
about the world when I was a senior in
high school those things changed
dramatically and it was it's a
combination of all of the classes that I
took a combination of all of the things
that I learned and also things that I
learned outside of classrooms of course
but but I don't know that we know how
deeply we have been built by the things
that we are asked to read or engage with
in school or in life but I but in my
feet like I truly feel that like I am
constructed out of the conversations
I've had and the stories that I've had
and and the thoughts that I've had and
the things that have been shared with me
and and hopefully in in your English
class as well as in other
things like you have been constructed
into a more full and interesting person
and that might not help you with your
computer science degree but it might
very well have helped you with with
asking interesting questions about you
our past and your future and and
engaging with other people in the world
that you are going to inhabit for the
next hopefully 60 or 70 years of your
life so I was gonna say at least 200
well you never know give the man some
credit he lives he lives in a glorious
future that you and I will never glimpse
it because we are so much older than yes
I suspect I'm gonna take the over under
on his remaining years at a hundred you
think so that's greatness for Alex no
congratulations Alex on on what will no
doubt now that I have gambled on you be
an incredibly long life all right well
maybe Alex will be the one who codes his
his consciousness into the computer for
the very first time and then Alex's
consciousness will will become sort of
the overarching morality of the entire
entire world and will control all of our
actions but in a way that makes us live
happy and fulfilled lives
no pressure Alex let's get to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon Hank what's
the news from Mars so that I can get to
the amazing news
well John as you know on the surface of
Mars are boring sorry what the news from
Mars is that as you know John there are
these these features called recurring
slope lineae which have been have been
showing up in in areas of Mars that art
that are deep depressions they show up
in the summer months so when it's warmer
and and there's much debate about what
these things are made of and they look
for all the world like water seeping
into the sand of Mars they come in the
summer they flow down the slopes and
then in the winter they they seem to to
sort of evaporate slowly but they they
show up pretty fast and and and and
these are an area of tremendous interest
and study the the there's no super
consensus but most people think that
they are probably it's probably super
salty water super salty liquid water
pouring
down the slopes of Martian craters and
valleys and that is very cool but now
there is a huge amount of discussion
going on not just about what these
things are made of and and their
properties and how they're where they're
coming from how the the water might
being vampy being recharged but how we
might actually explore them and the
potential problems that might show up
when exploring them because it may be
that these areas are very muddy and so a
rover would just sink right in it's also
if there's going to be an existing
ecology on Mars then it's very likely
that that this is a place where that
ecology would be thriving because
there's liquid water and if there is
liquid water and there is an ecology
then we have to be very careful about
exploring that area because if there's
any earth borne bacteria that is
introduced to this environment that
could potentially survive that they
could that could totally wreck the
existing ecology and Andrew up ruin our
our one chance possibly our only chance
to ever observe non terrestrial life and
how it might have evolved on another
planet so there is a very heated
discussion going on in the Mars
community right now particularly
particularly regarding the Mars 2020
Rover that will hopefully land on Mars
in the 2020s and and and and whether
that Rover should should investigate
these things particularly because they
might be an ecological place or whether
these whether these uh these are SLS if
they're called should be preserved as a
kind of a kind of like an area of Mars
that should not be ventured into until
we know more about it until and until we
have a better ability to explore without
the possibility of bacterial
contamination so that's what's going on
on the news from Mars today which I just
think is fascinating well let me just
tell you that the possibility of
bacterial contamination is a hundred
percent if I learned anything today it's
that my body is crawling with trillions
of bacteria that I have more cells that
are not me inside of me than I have
cells that are me so I cannot go to Mars
and touch anything or I will smear it in
bacteria that is from Earth
that is correct John well Hank that that
put me in the darkness but but I'll tell
you what put me in the light last
weekend
AFC Wimbledon were playing Notts County
League two rivals Notts County Hank I
know you're familiar with Notts County
it's where the Sheriff of Nottingham
Robin Hood etc of course so Notts County
Football Club is a well-established club
in the the Football League AFC Wimbledon
of course has only been in the league
since 2011 and they were they were down
one nil to Notts County in the 85th
minute you could just imagine the the
darkness ank as we were looking down the
table thinking are we going to be in
those relegation spots are we going to
be leaving the Football League are we
going to be relegated to the conference
so that we're not even a full-time
professional team anymore and you won't
see us in FIFA 17 or instead are we
gonna go from one nil down to two one up
that's what happened Hank in the 85th
minute we were down one nil but then a
miracle happened and we scored two goals
in the final five minutes of the game to
come from behind before four thousand
people 2,000 of whom were in the John
Green stand and win 2-1 against Notts
County you'll never guess who scored the
second goal Hank just kidding you will
it was the Beast Auto Biola can phenoix
our greatest player the largest man in
professional football the strongest
player in FIFA 16 the Beast
autobiography no scores in the 90th
minute AFC Wimbledon come from behind to
win against Notts County suddenly we are
12th in league two we have a zero goal
differential which means we've scored as
many goals over the course the season as
we've given up I am full of hope I am
beginning to dream oh it was beautiful
that sounds really exciting John oh my
god you can't even it was just it wasn't
it was incredible two goals in five
minutes - to secure the victory and and
everything is better and different and
and and hope springs eternal hope that
thing with feathers the irrepressible
audacious thing at the heart of all
human experience hope in
merged that morning in South London I
would also like to say that that that
AFC Wimbledon the club this week
welcomed aid workers from around the
world who have been working especially
on the refugee crisis that that
Wimbledon welcomed a bunch of aid
workers from from around the world to to
South London and gave them a great
experience over the weekend so that that
speaks I think to the kind of club that
it is owned by its fans Hank now now one
5,600 owned by you because I just made
you a member of the the Dons trust I
just bought you a membership you can
Google AFC Wimbledon trust if you want
to become a member of the of the trust
but hanky you you can't do that because
I already made you well thank you very
much I'm honored do but what did we
learn today John well we learned that
it's just incredibly incredibly
important for 15 year-olds to drive
carefully and if at all possible with an
adult at all times
we learned that both Hank and John
actually think that English class is
important even if John thinks that it's
important in different ways than Hank
does and of course we learned that the
human body is not really a human body at
all instead it's a large container of
bacteria it is essentially just a
sausage casing in which the sausage is
not a person but is a teeming mass of
parasites I also want to say that last
time we talked about how nerdcon stories
are our event in Minneapolis which is
going to be amazing was going to be on
October 10th in 11th that was a lie it
is going to be on October 9th and 10th
so those are the actual dates of nerdcon
stories don't show up on the 10th
because it starts on the 9th just like
it says on your ticket if you got one if
you don't got one we still got a few
left and you are welcome to purchase
them
thank you remember when you tried to
comfort me by telling me that there was
only like eight to ten pounds of
bacteria
inside of my body at any given moment I
said three to eight three to eight oh
there's only there's only three to eight
first off that's an incredibly wide
range how do i how do I get one of the
bodies that has how do I get one of the
bodies that has three pounds of bacteria
I don't want one of the bodies that has
eight pounds um well there people are
doing very different sizes I don't know
if you know that probably means that I'm
on the bigger side right I probably have
six pounds of bacteria inside of me
right now six pounds of not me inside of
me now whenever one whenever anyone asks
for my weight I'm going to give my
weight minus six pounds because that
isn't my weight it's the bacteria inside
of oh man I hope that I'm right about
the six pounds of bacteria thing
whatever if we're not will correct it in
next week's podcast our podcast is
edited by our good friend Nick Jenkins
have the theme music is from gunnarolla
and if you want to email us you can do
so at Hank and John at gmail.com we'll
try to answer as many of your questions
as possible you can also follow us on
the Twitter Hank green and John Green or
on Instagram where Hank is Hank green
and I am John Green writes books the
worst Instagram username ever sorry oh
well I haven't been using Instagram at
all lately so you can follow me on
snapchat
it's Hank GRE god I wish you would get
over snapchat I love snapchat so much
thank you so much for listening and as
we say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
you